hey guys i'm off the grid for august but
here's a noted right-wing lunatic saying
something that actually completely makes
sense
final words final words for you guys
well i agree we have to impeach majorcas
it's a priority of mine as well but i
want people to know that the wall in
south texas actually was built during
the obama administration
and yet during that time no one called
it racist
you know and that just shows the
hypocrisy
and i'm all about giving our border
patrol agents the resources that they
need but right now it's really the
policies this administration is putting
in policies that are encouraging illegal
immigration and also there is
organizations in the united states that
are going to south america that are
going to mexico and literally paying for
their hotel for their food
to come here to the united states and
they are taking advantage of these
people that are in need that are wanting
to escape crime i
of course i'm against illegal
immigration but it's also people from
here from this country that are
literally paying the pain the entire way
and and that's something that it's
important that we understand that we
have our own enemy within
and
and there is good people
you know i want y'all to know there is
good people wanting to come here to work
hard for the american dream but we want
them to come here legally and that is
and that is why it's so important that
we fix the immigration system because it
is broken there's people that have been
waiting 15 20 years to come here to the
united states so we have to fix the
legal process so good people can come
here to united states and
that is also a priority of mine as well